next time I'll show you how to make
money on YouTube
[Music]
[Applause]
Ren got me today something very special
happens on the Sam and Nico Channel
today we're building our own website
it's gonna be called smeller now thanks
to our friends at Squarespace for making
this video possible because without them
we would have never discovered this it's
a website where you can upload any image
you want and it will tell you what that
image smells like isn't that amazing
thanks to their all-in-one platform
there's nothing to install patch or
upgrade ever meaning that your images
will smell the same all day everywhere
you go no matter what you do hitting the
smeller domain which is a PC using their
fully transparent domain experience when
I'm driving I like to roll the window
down and just tag smells cuz Unseld you
can get points for each smell you tag
like Yelp it's kind of like Yelp and a
little bit like ways on smeller you can
tag the location I do the smell with the
description but your friends can go
there and smell it too there's a whole
bunch of geotagged weed smells up here I
see weed themes on here you send friends
on smell or elf sniff you can tag your
friends in the smell as well sniff you
send them a sniff oh it's like saying
hey what's up kind of returns back a
popular smell in their area know when
you're being sniffed you get a little
alert saying so-and-so is sniffing you
like what I love about this smeller site
on Squarespace is that it's it's mobile
optimized so you can bring it on the go
if you're sitting at home wondering why
am I not capable of
with a genius idea like smeller have no
fear because their templates are
flexible for any kind of website I mean
just think no one's done the world's
first online Braille Bible yet so get
your boat over to squarespace.com now
and use the offer code Sam and Nico to
get 10% of your first purchase
also keep an eye out for the smeller
companion apps sniffer which is gonna be
available early next year and it's gonna
allow you to go mobile anywhere what's
that smell
previously these guys just make fun of
me because of my allergies they don't
have a good sense of smell but now I can
use smell or just like fit right in back
to the social norm or even I'll just
smell things together all the time
ooh that smells good I bet you can't
figure out what we're smelling right now
yeah cheeseburgers smell delicious man
since when do you know cheeseburgers
smelling tune in this Friday at 4 p.m.
for the ultimate live stream we're going
to set up next iPhone in the middle of
an archery target and stream from that
phone so we're gonna be shooting arrows
at you the viewer trying not to hit the
phone but getting as close as possible
the closest one wins first person hits
the phone loses and probably stand by
everybody else burritos this Friday at 4
p.m. follow us on Facebook link in the
description below a facebook.com slash
corridor digital also on Instagram we're
going to be live streaming there as well
from a second point of view follow us
there at corridor digital links all in
the description go check it out this
Friday at 4 p.m. Pacific I'll see you
there hi I'm Christian and I'm the
business and production manager here at
corridor digital in my years of my
youtube career so far I've had the
pleasure of working with channels like
Roman Atwood Suzi - just kidding news
Jimmy Tatro work - the MC n like studio
71 so let's say you're getting some
views and your channels growing and
you're getting some traction and you're
looking to make more money than just the
regular Google Adsense one of the ways
to do that is branded or sponsored
videos so you have a company that has
reached out to you that is looking to
pay you to help promote or showcase
their product or brand so now you have a
potential brand deal on the table so how
do you know how to manage
act on these brand deals well first you
should know how they work think of a
stepladder at the top of this stepladder
there's the brand in our example we're
gonna use nerf so nerf has a company
that has all kinds of different
departments from creative execs to a
legal team all the way down to managers
coordinators and assistant unnerve has
decided they want to do a marketing
campaign on their newest plastic so they
go out and hire a creative or marketing
agency now that creative a marketing
agency has many departments within its
own right from creative execs to legal
and so on so when nerf and their agency
have figured out their overall goals and
the creators they want to work with they
then have to go reach out to the MC ends
the managers or even to the creators
directly and that's where we land on the
ladder we are the creators
so now nerf or most likely through their
creative agency has reached out to us
and they've sent us an offer which
includes key messaging and required
talking points an overall campaign goal
and a budget that they are willing to
pay us in return for releasing our
sponsored video on our channel to our
audience so we've agreed we like the
terms everything that looks good we send
a creative treatment and we have to send
that creative treatment all the way back
up the ladder through all those
departments gets approved and the
approval gets sent back down to us with
the green light to move forward in some
cases you'll get notes and stuff like
that but overall you're just looking to
get the green light to move forward on
the production so once we got that all
in agreement it's on now on us to create
and deliver the best video we can per
what we've agreed upon and what we want
to be able to put out with our creative
vision behind it all the creative agency
departments and all the brand
departments they all get an opportunity
to raise their questions or concerns
with anything that we have in the video
whether it's we didn't say a key
messaging point right we forgot to
include one entirely whatever it is this
is their chance to express their concern
once everything is approved and
everybody's happy we launched the video
on our channel so you've done all that
work you've done everything that's
agreed upon and it's not until now that
you get to ask for money and depending
on how big of a company you're working
with you could be waiting 30 60 or 90
days after the submission of an invoice
to get paid that's just the game there's
a video that's pretty interesting I
wanted to get your reactions to it Sam
and Nico thumbnail tutorial they have
this corridor tag up here with the
yellow yellow border which kind of helps
the viewer know that it's one of their
videos I think they were talking about
that in the video where one of them
geniusly
created the logo for the Sam and Nico
channel by just inverting the colors and
everything from scratch
you have templates for everything yeah
so templates and have a master Fox I
just throw everything master file we're
gonna start with these anime lines and
you can just do what I'm doing where you
take the selection tool draw the little
random daggers going into the screen
towards the center enemy lines are kind
of a pain to me suppose the Gaul from a
perspective point all lines point to
that middle that's what makes the
effective enemy lines
yes of mine wait what subscribe one word
and it was that word I haven't watched
the video but it's like we have a fairly
straightforward system to our thumbnails
a lot of thought actually goes into them
even though everyone seems to think that
we don't put any thought towards the
thumbnails they kind of broke it down
fairly well from what I could see mine I
use shape legs you just said it again
you're not gonna be able to get through
this tutorial man I know out there
really be careful now now what's the
main difference between that and his
lines are kind of going everywhere and
with enemy lines you're supposed to go
to a focal point so I've made mine all
go to the middle dude
[Music]
yeah so I made it really big
oh so you're only using a little section
of it yeah is it vector-based because it
is shape layers which is vector based
there is no pixelation so you can scale
it up to like 500 million percent and
you'll still have those crisp lines you
don't want actually to see this point in
the middle so I add a mask okay yeah you
don't want so usually the subject is
right in the middle so you want the
enemy lines pointed right to the subject
or whatever you want to focus on mine
are pretty big I guess I really wanted
to put three important key tips that I
think will help you moving forward
whether you're doing a twenty dollar a
two hundred dollar or a two hundred
thousand dollar brand new key tip number
one is communicate do not be afraid to
ask questions sometimes a brand or
agency might come in with a weird ask or
request that you're just not familiar
with or maybe have some reservations
about there is no problem asking for
clarification trust me on this it is
better to figure it out in the beginning
of the process versus near the end when
you're this close to the finish line tip
number two be flexible more often than
not a brand is gonna come in with stuff
that is not part of your usual content
strategy so be willing to push the
envelope a little bit and maybe try some
new things to see if your audience likes
it lastly and it may sound like I'm
contradicting my last tip a little bit
the last thing I want to leave you with
is do not compromise your overall brand
and creative vision you're the one that
knows your audience best it's your
audience so when you're dealing with
these brands and creative agencies learn
to pick your battles but also stand up
for what you believe in stand up for
your ideas because at the end of the day
you're just working with other people so
if you can be professional respect the
people you're working with and stay true
to your word that makes you a good brand
partner and when you're a good brand
partner brands of all shapes and sizes
come back to you tie
and time again to promote through your
channel and that's how you make money on
YouTube follow us on Instagram and
Facebook nico nico hit personally Nico
personally has taken three hours to get
these shots am I happy about it
do I look happy about it
links in the description below